- Okay, so it's been almost 10 years
since the last Twilight saga movie
but our love of Bella, Edward,
and, of course, Jacob,
hasn't gone anywhere.
A new generation of
supernatural loving fans
are even discovering the story today
as we were talking about earlier
so it's time for a game,
we're calling Twilight Never Fades.
♪ Twilight Never Fades ♪
Oh my God, I love y'all's intros.
They're so great.
We need a host from another realm.
God, any help?
- [God] I'm here, Kelly,
how you doing girl?
- I'm so good.
Happy New Year, God!
- [God] Oh, happy New Year to you
and hey Taylor, how you doing?
- I'm so good!
- [God] Boy, I'll tell you,
one of my finest
creations, this young man.
I broke the mold when I made you, son.
I'll tell you that.
- Thank you!
- [God] I am team Jacob all the way,
you ain't got to worry about that.
Uh-uh. Uh-uh.
- He is not a traitor.
Could you set up the game for us, God?
- [God] Well, absolutely.
Now this here is a game
about the Twilight saga trivia, okay?
Now the question could be from
any one of the five films.
I'm going to ask a question about the plot
or characters of Twilight.
And if you know the answer,
you just buzz in and
give it your best shot.
And because there are no rules
when it comes to love and teenage angst,
steals are allowed.
Alright?
- Yeah, alright.
Alright.
- [God] Okay, get ready.
- Okay
- [God] Here is your first question:
What is Bella Swan's dad's job?
(Taylor's buzzer rings)
- Oh God, oh!
- He's a cop.
- [Kelly] He's a cop.
- Yeah, he's a cop.
- [Kelly] I knew that one.
- He is the chief of police.
- Okay.
- [God] Here's the next one?
What color were Bella's eyes
when she became a newborn
vampire in Breaking Dawn?
- They were hazel.
Aren't they the other way,
so that when you eat? Oh.
- I am sorry.
- Oh when you have blood, you get hazelly.
They are like yellowy, hazelly.
- No, that's you really
stretching it, Kelly.
- Oh God.
- What were they like gold or like amber?
(Buzzer beeping)
Okay.
- Okay, he didn't even know.
I don't feel bad.
- What the hell was going on here?
- Wait there, wait....
- The correct answer was red.
- Okay
- It was hard to color coordinate outfits.
- Wow, this is embarrassing.
- Okay.
- It sounds vaguely familiar now.
- Kelly, either way, you're still losing.
So let's move on.
- Thank you God, thank
you for the remainder.
- Thank you.
- A big help.
- I'm always here to help.
- Okay.
- Here's the next question.
Kelly, this is your big chance.
- I am trying.
- Bella moves to the town of forks
at the beginning of the franchise,
but where did she move?
- Arizona
- That is correct.
- Yes.....
- She was from Phoenix, Arizona.
- Nice.
- That explains a lot, actually.
That explains a lot.
- I love it, I love it.
- People in Phoenix, out their minds.
- [God] Okay, Kelly.
- I just don't wanna
to get like one right.
- You on the board.
You got one point.
- Okay, okay.
- You're on the board.
Here's your next question .
In eclipse, what power does Alice have?
- Oh...oh.
- She can see the future.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I knew that one.
Oh, so oops.
Oops.
It's it's lit up. Cause I hit it.
It's like my chair turned.
- Well, you still don't get the point.
You still don't get.
- I know God.
- You can hit that
thing all you want girl,
but you ain't going get no point for me.
- I knew that one.
- Here's the next question?
What sport did the vampires
play in the first movie?
- Baseball.
- Correct, Baseball!!! We have a tie.
- And when the lightning hits,
they're gonna play in the storm.
See I watch the movies under the book.
I should win this. Wait a minute.
- That's right, okay.
- Okay
- Baseball, baseball.
One thing they don't suck at.
- We did it, did it.
- Okay, here we go.
- Wow.
- Oh my God.
- It's loaded.
- [God] Here's the next one?
This is it. We have a tie and
this is the final question.
- Tie breaker, tie breaker.
- Oh man, this is worth 35 points.
That's a random number I
just made up right now.
Who says "Isabella Swan, I promise
to love you Every moment of forever."
- Edward
- It is Edward.
And at loos, the Taylor
- Whatever.
- [God] Is our winner.
You have done it.
- Whatever Taylor, you were in the movie.
- So I had an advantage.
- Oh...and now for the lamest part
of the show because Taylor won,
his photo, we'll mountain on
the blank shountain wall of champions
to beat Kelly Clarkson.
It's a dumb law.